[Musica]
tempo l'intuizione e la rappresentazione
della modalità secondo la quale i
singoli eventi si susseguono e sono in
rapporto l'uno con l'altro per cui essi
avvengono prima dopo o durante altri
eventi
il tempo il tempo è un argomento che da
sempre mi ha molto affascinato
anzi penso di avere iniziato a studiare
fisica proprio perché volevo cercare di
capirlo meglio ma che cos'è il tempo
sant'agostino in un celebre passo delle
confessioni diceva che cos'è il tempo
se nessuno me lo chiede lo so bene
ma se qualcuno me lo chiede non lo so
più
noi siamo abituati a pensare al tempo
come un susseguirsi sempre uguali
distanti qualcosa che è il di fuori di
noi che scorre indipendentemente da noi
sempre uguale eppure in questo periodo
come non mai
quando siamo stati costretti tanto tempo
in casa per cercare di frenare
trasmissione il contagio della pandemia
da kobe 19
abbiamo capito che il tempo a volte
sembra fermarsi
certo non del vero senso della parola
il tempo si ferma davvero solo in rari
casi come per esempio durante i film di
fantascienza oppure in qualche
particolare teteks dove magia e fisica
si incontrano e allora il tempo si ferma
e poi basta uno schiocco di dita perché
torni a scorrere normalmente ma nella
vita di tutti i giorni
questo non succede però c'è una cosa
strana che fa il tempo il tempo non
scorre sempre uguale
per esempio quando siete al mare il
tempo scorre più lentamente che montano
e non perché a sciare ci si diverta di
più rispetto a fare i tuffi ma perché il
tempo scorre più lentamente vicino a una
grande massa e quale massa più grande
dell'intera terra allo stesso modo il
tempo scorre in modo diverso a seconda
di come vi muovete per esempio se siete
su un aereo supersonico il tempo
scorrerà più lentamente rispetto a
quando siete fermi davanti al computer a
guardare come un video come questo
insomma anche se in modo impercettibile
star lì al computer a guardare questo
video vi sta facendo invecchiare più
velocemente
l'idea come il tempo fatto da un
susseguirsi distanti tutti uguali e
inizia a sgretolarsi e mi piacerebbe
adesso potervi dire che il tempo non
solo può scorrere più lentamente o più
velocemente ma può anche scorrere
all'indietro che si può tornare indietro
nel tempo
e invece no purtroppo questo non è
possibile
così come non è possibile che una
lattina vuota è accartocciata possa
tornare integra
è piena se il tempo nella realtà non può
scorrere all'indietro è tutta colpa del
calore
e sì perché il calore possiede una
proprietà unica nel mondo della fisica
crea dei cambiamenti irreversibili
dipende tutto dal secondo principio
della termodinamica che dice che se
nient'altro intorno cambia il calore non
può mai passare dal corpo più freddo a
quello più caldo è tutto qui se
prendiamo le leggi del moto non c'è
nulla che impedisca al tempo di scorrere
all'indietro
se non ci fosse l'attrito per cui viene
disperso del calore quando facciamo
rimbalzare una pallina di plastica non
potremmo mai dire se il tempo sta
scorrendo in avanti o indietro è la
banale ragione per cui il ghiaccio
sciogliendosi torna a essere acqua ma
l'acqua se non la mettete nel
congelatore non può mai trasformarsi in
ghiaccio
[Musica]
beh a meno che hanno sappiate fare una
magia ovviamente
ma perché il calore si comporta in
questo modo per capirlo dobbiamo prima
farci un'altra domanda che cos'è il
calore per molto tempo si è pensato che
il calore fosse una sorta di fluido che
poteva andare da un corpo all'altro ma
poi il grande bossman capi che realtà
dipendeva dall'agitazione microscopica
delle molecole in un cubetto di ghiaccio
le molecole sono quasi ferma un po come
voi adesso anche se non posso vederli
invece quando un liquido bolle le
molecole si agitano come come dei morti
che stanno pagando al rave party e
ballando all'aumento della temperatura
quindi corrisponde un passaggio da uno
stato più ordinato le molecole più ferme
a uno più disordinato le molecole che si
muovono velocemente ma che significa
quando parliamo di molecole ordinato o
disordinato e già difficile riuscire a
darne una definizione nella vita di
tutti i giorni
pensate a quando i vostri coinquilini o
genitori si lamentano perché avete
lasciato la stanza in disordine e invece
per voi era sufficientemente ordinata
per capire cosa significa ordine e
disordine quando parliamo di molecole
facciamo un esempio io qui ho otto carte
immaginiamo che ognuna di queste carte
corrisponde una molecola è disordinare
le carte significa mescolarle ora se io
mescola 8 carte posso ottenere 40.320
combinazioni diverse di queste saranno
ordinate e quali disordinate per esempio
se vi faccio vedere quest'ordine questa
combinazione iniziale
secondo voi è ordinata o disordinata beh
io dire ordinata perché
tutto sommato abbiamo quattro carte
rosse da una parte e quattro carte nere
dall'altra se adesso andiamo a mischiare
queste carte
probabilmente non otterremo più lo
stesso ordine di colore e avremo quindi
che le carte sono disordinate e infatti
l'ordine con il colore si è perso ma se
fate attenzione vedete che è comparso un
nuovo ordine
adesso le carte sono ordinate
numericamente dall'asso all 8 beh ordine
per colore o per numero sono solo due
delle possibili grandezze diciamo
riferite alla carte alle carte che noi
possiamo vedere con cui possiamo quindi
associare delle particolari combinazioni
e dare un particolare significato a
queste combinazioni
adesso dopo un nuovo miscuglio le carte
probabilmente è infatti lo sono non sono
più ordinate né per colore né per numero
ma se fate molta attenzione potreste
trovare un nuovo ordine
l'ordine con tutte le carte dispari da
una parte e tutte le carte pari dall
altra cosa voglio dirvi che in realtà
ognuna di queste combinazioni alla
stessa identica probabilità di uscire
dopo un miscuglio siamo noi che diamo un
significato particolare ad alcune di
queste combinazioni e quindi
consideriamo delle combinazioni più
probabili e alcune più improbabile
diciamo che sono più improbabili quelle
a cui noi associamo un ordine
particolare e adesso dopo un nuovo
miscuglio cosa abbiamo ottenuto vi dice
niente quest'ordine
probabilmente no ma solo perché il modo
in cui voi potete vedere la realtà
non è completo se potete vedere anche
attraverso le carte vedreste che in
realtà si è formato un nuovo ordine
una parola che per noi ha un grande
significato entropia l'entropia è la
quantità che conta quante combinazioni
noi non riusciamo a distinguere e non
riusciamo a distinguere perché la nostra
visione della realtà è in realtà sfocata
la percepiamo sono in modo limitato a
quelli che sono i nostri sensi e i
nostri strumenti l'entropia
nell'universo non può mai diminuire ogni
volta che c'è una trasformazione
naturale l'entropia aumenta un po il
disordine aumenta un po ma abbiamo visto
che ordine e disordine dipendono da come
noi guardiamo la realtà è questa è la
rivoluzione perché in realtà a livello
microscopico ordine e disordine non sono
esattamente quello che noi pensiamo e
quindi anche la freccia del tempo smette
di esistere
il tempo non è una proprietà del mondo
ma è un modo in cui noi lo percepiamo
dipende da noi se potessimo vedere la
realtà con tutti i dettagli possibili e
immaginabili riusciremmo a sempre a
trovare un ordine nelle cose e anche per
noi il tempo smetterebbe di esistere di
ho confuso lo so
il tempo non è un argomento facile
nemmeno i fisici più brillanti sono
riusciti a comprenderlo fino in fondo ma
quello che ci importa per vivere bene e
quello che diceva einstein
il tempo è relativo è il suo unico
valore dipende da ciò che noi facciamo
mentre sta passando
insomma non lasciate che il vostro tempo
passi tra parentesi
[Musica]